where do you think the future of the
industry is given how far left the
industry itself is moving we had this
announcement in the past few weeks that
the academy awards is now only going to
be
looking at staffing of particular films
certain percentages of black or gay or
hispanic or women
that the plot line has to revolve around
one of these minority groups
uh one of these criteria has to be
applied which you know basically rules
out nearly every oscar winner between
1933 and
effectively 2007. so we've gotten off
off a little bit not a little bit we've
gotten off
and we think that we're doing something
these people think that they're doing
something
generous and kind
the this racial disturbance that we're
looking at
was was created i i
you know if you look back at the we
mentioned the um
the frankfurt school some of the stuff
that they talked about gender stuff and
stuff like that there was it was
inserted into this society
to break the family to break the
churches
to just to destroy some of the fabric
that keeps our country together
and that's what you're participating in
people say what about black lives matter
john and i say well if you're teaching
children
that they are victims
i say it's child abuse
we have every child can do
they're god's god's gift
make pave the way for them to be their
best selves
don't tell them that they're they can't
do this or can't do that
every child is a powerhouse spiritually
every every every human being
potentially is a power
spiritual powerhouse so let them be that
encourage that let them grow to their
full
height and uh and i think that
races are being used continuously that's
it
one of the things that's uh fascinating
to watch is is the
devolution of hollywood itself so it
used to be very centralized in la now
you do production everywhere
and uh because of digital streaming it's
not even as though there's a lot of
gatekeepers anymore so
are you hopeful that the kind of diffuse
nature of hollywood now that you can
produce a film
in the middle of nowhere with a small
budget that this is going to break up a
lot of the hollywood monopoly and allow
an opportunity for other kinds of
content to flourish i think that's
possible yes i think
you know you can make a film with an
iphone or something you know
i don't mean to just advertise iphones
photos but you know
they have this technology these days
everybody's got it you know every kid's
got it
so uh yes things are going to change but
there'll always be artists that use
this this painting this paint you know
in some way to to give us something and
they have to be
sound of mind and heart that's what they
have to be
so i i see myself i see
uh the hope is
where's the hope i say well i'm
as i've come along to understand myself
a little bit better
i've understood
the importance of god
and i'm a person who loves all people
of all faiths
and i say god is not sleeping
and i said this in israel one time i
said watch out
because melchizedek when he had the
writing on the wall
you know that was his doom
it was written on the wall god has a way
of helping the good you know
and now is the time when we need god
most and i think that something's hap
i think something is going to happen
here i think something is happening
with people uh righteous people are
coming to the fore
so many good righteous people we know
you know
even you know splendid people
of great courage of great intelligence
of great kindness and uh
and they're saying come along let's
let's come back together let's
let's pull ourselves back and uh and
heal that's what i say too i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show sunday special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all our future
content